as the delta sigma phi beta kappa
variant of the wu flu reportedly rages
around the country democrat states and
counties are turning the tyranny up to
11. even some prominent republicans are
joining the calls to get you masked
faxed and locked back in your home
including the governator who does not
think very highly of your freedom
there is a virus here it kills people
and the only way we prevented this is we
get vaccinated to wear masks to do
social distancing washing your hands all
the time and not just to think about
well my freedom is being kind of
disturbed here no screw your freedom
because with freedom comes obligations
and uh and have responsibilities we
cannot just say i have the right to the
x y and z when you affect other people
quite an about face we've gone from
don't be a girly man to wear your mask
and hide in your home my schwarzenegger
is not that good believe it or not
schwarzenegger is actually moderate in
his views compared to the rest of the
world where some uh different countries
health officers are calling for an end
to conversation in the name of saving
lives meanwhile federal judge tries to
lock up capital rioters and throw away
the key even as minnesota democrats
celebrate the george floyd arsonists
lots of people are going along with
these new rules in the hopes of getting
back to normal how long before they all
realize this is the new normal i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from deborah
gessner who says we have now reached
heard stupidity we i'm glad that that is
spread throughout though frankly i
actually don't think that the stupidity
and the inanity and the neurotic
aspect of this whole virus is among the
people so much as it is among
the
ruling class the ruling class are the
ones pushing this i think people are
pushing back against it which is why
you're seeing members of the ruling
class come out and say screw your
freedom or you know don't have
conversations with your your neighbors i
think that's really the big divide
that's going on now when you want to
protect yourself against all that kind
of crazy turmoil i would recommend you
go check out acre gold inflation is
going way way way up every time there's
a new report the report shows that
inflation continues to rise and
expectations are that it'll rise even
higher which is why i like to hedge my
portfolio with physical gold now you
might be saying michael
physical gold's expensive i can't afford
all that at once well don't worry acre
has you covered acre gold has this
incredible new product where you can
subscribe to gold bars for as little as
30 dollars a month you pay each month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your house acres got a
new 100 a month subscription for a five
gram gold bar they'll keep you updated
every month then they ship it once you
meet the price threshold
i've really enjoyed investing in
precious metals i've really enjoyed my
physical acre gold head on over to get a
gold.com knowles today start investing
in physical gold make sure you go to
that url because acres giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre that's get acre goal dot com slash
knowles thank you aker gold for
supporting the show arnold
schwarzenegger
[Music]
sort of has a point he sort of could
have a point let's put it that way when
he says that with freedom comes
responsibility of course nobody denies
that with rights come duties and
obligations yeah of course
does that mean that because there is a
cough that's been going around the world
we need to
lock people in their homes out of their
businesses out of their churches take
away their civil liberties and shut down
travel shut down christmas shut down
thanksgiving shut down conversation
among your neighbors i don't think so
that seems to be a step too far but that
that is the line he is articulating and
don't forget arnold schwarzenegger is a
moderate republican he's not even a far
leftist and arnold schwarzenegger is
articulating the excuse that the ruling
class has relied on since the beginning
of this this lockdown namely
in the name of public health we can do
whatever we want and this is being taken
to an even crazier extreme not among the
austrians like schwarzenegger but among
the australians australia's uh chief
health officer dr carrie chant
has a message
for anyone who
has the audacity to leave their homes to
i don't know go grocery shopping or
something like that namely
keep your mouth shut
we all need to work together
we need to limit our movements
we need to consider whenever we leave
our house that anyone with us anyone we
come into contact with
could
convey the virus
so
whilst it is in human nature to engage
in conversation with others
to be
friendly um unfortunately this is not
the time to do that so even if you run
into your next door neighbor
in the shopping center in the coals
whilst you're at coleslaws or aldi or
any other
grocery shop don't start up a
conversation
now is the time for minimizing your
interactions with others
even if you've got a mask
do not think that affords total
protection we want to be absolutely sure
that as we go about our daily lives we
do not come into contact with anyone
else that would pose a risk
do you get it yet do you do you get what
this is really about i suspect you do
get what this is really about i suspect
if you're listening to this program
you've known what this is about since
the beginning but i think a lot of
people have not from the beginning many
of us said
this is not about a virus this is not
about the unique once in a millennium
global health threat this is a political
power grab to shut people up isolate
people and to take away their way of
life and their rights
it's literally the symbol of the of the
pandemic is a muzzle that you put over
your mouth and if you in any way
contradict the liberal establishment
narrative you'll be ostracized you'll be
kicked out of the public square you will
be de-platformed you'll be suspended
from social media accounts you will not
be
permitted to to espouse these sorts of
views in public
now
what this woman is saying in australia
is yes
yes the the muzzle is not just about
keeping the variance and the virus it's
actually about shutting you up about
keeping you quiet
from the beginning of the lockdown i
think there were well-intentioned and
naive people
who believed that if we just if we just
go along with it if we just compromise a
little bit on our rights and our way of
life and going to church and having our
businesses if we just give them okay
we'll just wear the masks
okay well maybe we'll just get the shot
okay maybe we'll just do this we'll do
that that that would be a way to go back
to normal
and what i said from the very beginning
and what a lot of us said from the very
beginning is no it's actually the
opposite wearing the masks in public is
not going to convince people to go back
to normal it's going to do the opposite
it's going to convince people that this
is a once in a millennium
insane terrifying most dangerous event
you've ever seen and so we can't go back
to normal when you see your neighbors
running around like banditos that does
not tell you things are normal it tells
you that things are quite extraordinary
and we've got to suspend our normal way
of life
every inch
that
we the people have given to the ruling
technocratic elite from the beginning of
this has only
further
harmed our situation has only taken away
more and more of our rights has only
taken away more and more of our way of
life has only encouraged them the 15
days to slow the spread that we granted
very quickly turned into well just just
maybe a couple more months to slow the
spread well maybe just another year to
slow the spread well maybe now we need
to find a cure well now maybe actually
we need to stop the surge well now we
need to let me check my notes abolish
conversation 15 days to abolish
conversation but then we'll go back to
normal right
i don't think so and this is coming to
the united states by the way this isn't
just staying down under in australia and
it's not just
some questionable austrian immigrants
who once were the governor of california
this is coming
to the united states the la city council
just voted
13-0
this was an absolute unanimous vote
for
vaccine mandates at restaurants movie
theaters and concert venues
they just did this in in france and very
thankfully by a stroke of of providence
i i left france before the vaccine
mandate went into effect so i was just
in france last week i was there for my
buddy's wedding fortunately the country
was not totally locked down yet you can
still come in from the united states
without a ton of regulations but the day
i flew out you had to start showing a
proof of vaccination to get in anywhere
i wanted to get a cup of coffee at the
airport
they demanded proof of vaccination to
get into the little cafe at the airport
all right get get the coffee on the
airplane or something that's fine by me
that could never happen here right it
already is
it already is happening here
and it's going to happen in new york i
mean la right now is passing measures
that are more draconian even than what's
going on in new york but it's going to
happen in washington dc it's going to
happen in chicago unless unless we push
back against that sort of thing
and
there's not going to be a compromise
it's not going to be well let's wear our
masks is that going no no either you say
no
or
you go along with it the councilman in
in la at the la city council paul couric
said quote frankly i'm tired of our
politicization of science and public
health
while people outside this building are
protesting that this is a violation of
their civil liberties angelinos are
dying unnecessarily
people die a lot of people die every day
you and i are gonna die we are i can
tell you with a hundred percent
certainty we are going to die no one
here gets out alive okay
everyone in history has died
you might have life everlasting you
might have there that's that's a whole
other aspect we'll get to that too but
you you are not going to get off this
rock alive okay and what the left has
done so spectacularly is
they have taken this one virus that has
caused deaths i'm not saying that the
virus hasn't caused deaths but they have
made it seem as though that is the only
cause of death
and of course the lockdowns have led to
other deaths as well deaths of despair
deaths of drug overdose debts of of not
getting your treatment for various
diseases cancer treatments for instance
suicides but that none of that counts
none of that all that matters is if you
die from this one particular virus and
as a result
you've got to take away people's civil
civil liberties listen to how incoherent
this statement is i'm tired of our
politicization
of science and public health
says the politician
public health is by definition political
the word political and the word public
are synonyms they mean the same thing
politics is how we all get along
together it's what we all do together
that's why some politicians use
scientific data to manipulate our
politics and he says stop politicizing
what he's saying is shut up that's what
that's all that means whatever they say
don't make this political all that means
is shut up
let me affect my political agenda and
you don't say boo about it and too many
people are going along with it
when you want to do things for yourself
like fix your own car i would strongly
recommend you check out rockauto.com so
you need a part for your car where do
you want to spend your day do you want
to spend your day in a hot
sticky
physical brick and mortar auto parts
store where they ask you a million
questions and then finally you get the
answers and then they go in the back and
they don't have the part and then they
go online probably to rockauto.com they
charge you twice as much and then you
got to wait a week to get the part or
or do you want to just wait in the
comfort of your own home go to
rockauto.com search their tremendous
catalog it's so simple to navigate even
i can do it find whatever part you need
for your car or truck get a fair price
always reliably low prices no gimmicks
and then get that part asap what do you
want i think probably you're going to
want the latter head on over to
rockauto.com right now it's a great
family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years now 20
years that is as far as i can tell
almost the entire history of the
internet go to rockauto.com see all
those parts available for your car truck
and then write knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you there is a
fight going on right now
between the people who want
vax mandates at the restaurants and the
movie theaters and in the schools and
the mask mandates everywhere and the
people overseas who want to abolish
conversation and the handful of
conservative politicians with a spine
one of those conservative politicians
that seems to have a spine
ron desantis ron desantis is standing up
he is threatening
to withhold pay
from broward county school
administrators who are violating the
state
anti-mask mandate rule by instituting a
mass mandate and what does that mean
this is kind of complicated and there's
so many layers to this
some schools in liberal places want to
force kids to wear masks
that's wrong
that's stupid they shouldn't do that
it's wrong for many many reasons
so
some misguided conservatives have said
well it's not government's place to tell
people that they can or cannot have mass
mandates right you know in this the
usual way that we've talked about policy
for the last 10 or 15 years is between
big government and free choice right but
but it's a little more complicated here
because
sure the big government of the school
board wants to take away the free choice
to wear a mask or not but then you've
got the big government of the state
coming in and taking away the free
choice of the school district and then
you've got the big government so i don't
think it's so simple as big government
versus small government i think it's so
simple as tyranny versus slavery i think
it's actually a question
of prudence
i think it's actually a question of the
substance of it should these kids be
forced to wear the masks and so desantis
goes in and he says
absolutely not we will not permit
school districts to force kids to wear
these stupid masks
so now the school boards are fighting
back against desantis especially in
broward county very corrupt school
district and they're saying no we're
going to we're going to do it anyway so
desantis is going in through the florida
department of education and is saying
that if these school districts force the
kids to wear the masks he's going to
take away their pay
this is
frankly reagan-esque people have been
making a comparison between ron desantis
and donald trump recently because he's
doing all the hand gestures you know and
he's his skin seems to be getting
slightly more orange
he's probably got a can of you know
yellow hairspray in the corner he's
clearly running in the trump lane
but my pal andrew clavin pointed out
it's it's less trump that that desantis
is going for and a little more ronald
reagan and this line
to the school administrators it it
reminds you of of ronald reagan when the
air traffic controllers illegally went
on strike
i must tell those who fail to report for
duty this morning
they are in violation of the law
and if they do not report for work
within 48 hours they have forfeited
their jobs and will be terminated
such strong action as your first action
why not a
lesser accident
what
lesser action can there be the law is
very explicit
they are violating the law
and as i say we call this to the
attention of their leadership whether
this was conveyed to the membership
before they voted to strike i don't know
but this is one of the reasons why there
could be no further negotiation while
this situation
uh continues
you can't sit and negotiate
with a union that's in violation of the
law and their oath and their oath
classic reagan
what lesser action can there be they're
in violation of the law and this ought
to be our attitude too there is no
reconciliation there is no negotiation
here the negotiation has failed the
negotiation has lost us everything
because we thought that we could
negotiate in good faith here on how to
return to our normal way of life and we
can't they just lied to us they lied to
us about everything they lied to us
about the masks they lied to us about
the 15 days they lied to us about the
vax mandates they just lied to us about
everything they're not playing in good
faith they're idiots frankly they're
they're
incompetent at best and they're liars
and deceivers at worst
and more likely so i just don't think we
should play that game it's also not
going to be a battle between individual
autonomy and strong government the real
battle is going to be between their
strong government and our strong
government and one of the worst mistakes
that the right has made in recent years
is that we have given up political power
what we have done we've taken andrew
breitbart's basically true statement
that politics is downstream of culture
and we have allowed republican
politicians to use that as an excuse not
to do their job
politics is downstream of culture does
not mean that you completely give up the
government the political sphere because
it's somehow unjust ever to rule it
means you use the government you use
political power on the happy occasions
that the people give it to you for just
purposes that's what ron desantis is
doing here he's saying oh you're going
to use your government power in broward
county to try to force this ridiculous
thing on children okay i'm going to use
my government power here in tallahassee
to stop you from doing that that's a
good thing we need to encourage
the largely cowardly republican
politicians to do just that
the left is not very happy that people
are pushing back against forcing the
kids to wear the masks there is a
liberal professor
you know i've got to give thanks to to
one of my favorite twitter accounts it's
called libs of tick tock
i do not
participate in tik tok i feel that xi
jinping has enough of my data already so
i don't need to give him any more of it
also as far as i can tell
tik tok is just like 16 year olds
jiggling around and i don't want to
unwittingly commit a felony so i'm i
don't i don't look at that app but there
are great clips that go on tiktok and so
i'll see them on twitter from lives of
tick tock so there's this this gal
rachel kessler rachel kessler is a
liberal professor at kenyon college she
also styles herself a priestess of some
sort some sort of kooky cult or
something
uh
so she calls herself reverend the
reverend professor
rachel kessler
uh has come out now
screaming crying wailing rending her
garments and gnashing her teeth because
at her children's school district
they're not going to force all the
little kids to muzzle themselves i need
to go home instead i'm sitting at my
desk crying because we just got word
from our superintendent that masks will
not be required in our school district
this year because the school has to
respect the choice of parents that don't
want to have their kids in a mask
and that's just the most [ __ ]
reasoning and i'm so over it because
there is no such thing as a personal
choice in a pandemic because i have no
choice
now to send my child to school in a way
that will be safe for them because my
child's mask will do a great job of
protecting the other kids around her but
i have no choice not to have my kid
coughed on
by her classmates
i am so tired of this i'll do what works
for me you do what works for you take on
a public health crisis and we are never
gonna get out of this if we cannot start
collectively thinking about how our
actions impact the people around us she
said one thing there that's probably
true did you catch what it was
we are never going to get out of this
that that was the only thing she said
that might very well be true now her
argument is we're never going to get out
of this if we don't give in to all the
new measures and give up all of our
rights and upend the standards of
society of course the opposite is true
we're never going to get out of this if
we do
constantly wear the mask and allow them
to jab us with whatever they want and
give up all of our rights and give up
our churches and give up our business
that that's the way we're never going to
get out of it because when when people
take power they usually don't want to
give it back they don't give it back
very easily and she has another
interesting line there
she says
there is no such thing as individual
choice
during a pandemic
right
right that that's the premise
that's the whole premise and so the
pandemic can never end
and so when the pandemic is ending
you've got to change the rules which
they have done now like five times
you've got to ch so the goal has to go
from flatten the curve
to
slow the spread to find a cure to
spread the cure to everybody to stop the
surge they're already talking about the
the what the lambda the sigma variant
the there's going to be a million more
variants
and it will never
end because they don't want you to have
individual choice because they basically
agree with arnold sch screw your freedom
i really have to work on my schwartz
everyone has a good schwarzenegger but
me
that's what they really believe is what
dr fauci said yesterday when he was
salivating
oh fauci was so happy he said i know all
you people
you want your individual liberty
but we cannot have that now and he just
you could he was so thrilled that he
could take more power from you for
himself dr faucio has never appeared on
a ballot anywhere no one has ever cast a
vote for dr fauci he has been in his
position of power
for
i think
what five presidential administrations
now let's see was reagan bush clinton
bush obama
obama trump biden seven presidential
administrations this guy has been in
political power
so no they don't want they don't want
you to have any of that
what is the what is the pandemic what is
the pandemic
from the very beginning the death rate
was much much lower than people warned
us that it was going to be among
children which is what we were talking
about right here
way way way way lower beyond that we
know that the media and the scientific
establishment of the politicians have
been lying to us from the beginning and
when you compare it to other
not just other pandemics but even just
public public health problems you can
see in its context
not quite as big a risk as people have
made it out to be but as long as it
remains the pandemic
then your individual freedom your way of
life more importantly goes by the
wayside
you want to remember those good old days
when you had your way of life your
traditions your freedom i would strongly
recommend you check out legacy box one
of my most treasured possessions maybe
my single most treasured possession
is my collection of photographs and old
movies because you know i got i got some
nice stuff you know all sorts of nice
doodads and gizmos but those can be
replaced and your memories cannot and
what happens over time is that they fade
they start to deteriorate they degrade
and sometimes they get lost i've lost
some very important photographs or
sometimes they get destroyed in a fire
or sometimes they just they just don't
last that's why you need legacy box
today get it today
it's an affordable way to have the
priceless moments from your aging home
movies and photos safely stored in a
format you can access and share whenever
you want you mail in all those physical
pictures and movies legacy box will
digitize them by hand they'll send you
back
a
cd or they'll send you back a thumb
drive or they'll give you access on the
cloud and you will get your physical
memories back as well and then you get
to keep them preserved forever i love
legacy box i'm so pleased that they
digitized my memories go to
legacybox.com
knowles to take advantage of this
limited time offer for 50 off and
discover the magic of bringing your past
back into view anytime anywhere take
advantage of this exclusive offer today
then use it whenever you're ready that's
legacybox.comknowles to get 50 off
legacybox.com
knowles this crazy moment has been
called the authoritarian moment by none
other than ben shapiro that's his new
book it's available at barnes noble
amazon other major book sellers it is a
wonderful book to order
immediately after you order my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds it is i would say it's one of the
best
second books that you can order also
because it has my campaign slogan in the
title the authoritarian moment
if you sign up right now as a daily wire
member with code vip you will get 25 off
your new membership you will be
automatically entered to win a chance to
win a trip for two to the daily wire
studios in nashville to see candace live
not only will you meet candace herself
but you'll be getting an inside look at
her studio front row seats to watch your
show live maybe you'll meet me i hope so
they don't even put me in the copy here
dailywire.com subscribe code vip get 25
off be automatically entered to win
a chance at this vip experience how many
more ads do we have subscribe and listen
to the morning wire on apple podcast
spotify and everywhere you listen to
your podcasts so you don't miss a beat
is there anything else we got to
advertise here goodness gracious we'll
be right back with a lot more
the schools are the epicenter of the
fight right now because the schools
are the intersection of the family
they're the intersection
of the culture
they're
usually run by the government
they are a way to shape the next
generation if you want to look at what
your country is going to look like in 20
years look at a classroom a classroom is
a crystal ball
and so now there are battles going on
not just over whether the kids have to
muzzle themselves in class
but what the kids are going to be taught
and you've seen these battles on
critical race theory
people showing up to their school boards
to get the crazy gender theory and the
crazy crazy race theory out of the
classrooms
you've seen teachers during remote
learning say hey
make sure that the parents aren't paying
attention to what their kids are
learning on the computers make sure you
got to be very careful because if the
parents knew what their kids were
learning they'd get the teachers fired
as well they should
so there was a lesson plan that just
popped up from virginia this is a third
grade
lesson plan from the virginia state
education website
which
glorifies communism virginia department
of education
has third graders learning that police
hate black men
they have them watch a video that seems
to glorify communism the lesson first of
all the lesson plan is just written with
typos which
at the most basic level shows you the
state of american education but it's
provided for use by any teacher in the
state the lesson plan which is very
radical on gender theory very radical on
racial theory and explicitly marxist and
anti-american
the lesson plan was developed
by chesapeake public school teachers
their names are candace anthony
kazanov jamie marquis
they they have children especially
focusing on this this book a is for
activist a radical leftist book has no
place in the classroom so what should
happen here
what should happen
i think there are three schools of
thought there's the leftist school of
thought which is yes that's right that's
what education is about
it's not about teaching kids facts it's
not about teaching them how to think
in a critical way that's reasoned and
based on logic no it's about turning
them into activists to fight the system
even though we're the system by the way
it's about turning them into radicals
who are going to end depression so
that's the leftist view right this is
all great this is basically all that
they should be learning in schools
then there is the kind of squish view
with this is the view of the
conservatives for the past 10 15 years
which is well you know this isn't that's
not good that's been so okay they can
read their radical gender racial theory
in the classroom i don't want it
academic freedom i don't want to tell
them they can't but maybe could they
also possibly read a history book or
something maybe please right so that's
the the squish academic freedom view
then there is the conservative view
this is trash
this is harming children's education
this is harming
the children's
understanding of the world
it should be banned from the classroom
and the teachers behind it should be
fired
simple enough a teacher doesn't have a
right to go teach
nazism in the classroom a teacher
shouldn't have the right to teach
communism in the classroom
simple and i'm not saying teach about
nazism or communism that's why of course
they should teach about these things
but they shouldn't be able to teach
through this lens of ideology they
shouldn't be able to teach you yes
nazism is good hitler's awesome you
should all
gus goose march and zig heil
likewise they should not teach you
communism is good the tenets of
communism are wonderful and you should
all become communist activists fire them
academic freedom to quote william f
buckley jr as mainstream of conservative
as ever there was founded the post-war
conservative movement he said academic
freedom is a hoax it's a farce it's
never used
to justify teaching things that are more
conservative or right-wing
it's only ever used as an excuse to
teach your little kid that your little
boy that is a little girl or to teach
white kids that they're evil or to teach
you every child in america is a rotten
and terrible place and to teach them all
that communism's terrific
fire them fire them ban it from the
classroom some people get it again in
florida they're actually doing a pretty
good job at this
other republican politicians need to
follow suit speaking of child abuse you
know that
just a light topic for your morning
speaking of child abuse
there was an image
an award-winning image that was going
around the internet yesterday
that award-winning image was from
the netherlands
it's of a little kid i guess a little
girl i can't tell
uh sort of everyone's gender bending
these days so who knows but you know a
little a little child
at a swing set with a bunch of
creepy men wearing leather sort of
straps and little leather booty shorts
behind them obviously preparing for some
sort of perverted sexual thing
and they're all you know some of them
they're not really
engaging in any overtly sexual act but
they're all sort of hanging around
preparing to go
on some sort of perverted adventure
this just won a prize
the photo competition
was put out by pride this is one of you
know one of the pride organizations in
the netherlands
it was won by jan von breda
13 000 photos were submitted
uh
three of them won
this is the description this photo in
its composition child in the foreground
men preparing for canal pride in the
background
everyone busy with their own activities
and fascinations
sublimely depicts what will hopefully
remain self-evident that we
unhampered by prejudices and almost
unsuspectingly all may and can exist
side by side that's what the jury said
about this photo
you know if
if the consequence of getting rid of
prejudices is having kids play around
among a bunch of sick leather daddies
at a parade
maybe we could use a little more
prejudice uh maybe people haven't stood
up enough for prejud actually you know
who did stand up for prejudice as edmund
burke not prejudice in the sense of you
know i i'm gonna hate you because of
your skin color i'm gonna prejudice in
the sense of prejudgment
prejudice in the sense of we actually
can know things we actually know when we
have a natural visceral reaction to
seeing a bunch of these sickos like
oiling each other up around a little kid
that visceral reaction though it may not
be totally conscious and we might not
have like a ten paragraph reasoned
argument as to why why this situation is
bad
the reaction is right
that actually is bad
we shouldn't permit that these things
should not exist side by side the the
bdsm
people like whipping each other should
not exist side by side with the little
children
but but it raises a question also about
the limits of autonomy which is kind of
what we're all talking about today what
are the limits of freedom and
autonomy
we all know you look at that picture if
you're listening right now you can you
can google the picture later or maybe
you shouldn't because it's just gross
but when you look at that picture we all
know that there's something wrong with
that
but what's wrong with that
what's the prize is it just that it's
that there's a kid there
why is it wrong that there's a kid there
if there's nothing wrong with what the
guys are doing and they're kind of like
leather daddy costumes if there's
nothing wrong with that intrinsically
then why is it wrong that there's a kid
there
why should kids be protected from that
if there is something wrong with what
the guys are doing
with the kind of leather stuff in public
and you know getting a little in your
face then why are we encouraging it
why if there's something like so
disordered about this that we should
that we should protect children from it
then why are we encouraging it
for everyone else and and why are we
pretending by the way that you can
encourage all these sorts of things
everywhere ubiquitous in the middle of
main street for adults but yet somehow
protect kids from it you obviously you
cannot
we do not we are not totally isolated
beings we do live in a society we do
have neighbors we do want to talk to
people when we go outside even though
the australian health minister doesn't
want us to
why are we encouraging the liberty
to do things that we all agree are are
very bad
that i think that's actually a problem
for the right to figure out we're trying
to work on that right now there's a big
debate on the right over that and i
think that the kind of desiccated
libertinism of the last 10 or 15 years
is just complete it's deader than disco
man put that away with your bell bottoms
it is over now there is some good news
by the way coming from the departments
of health on on this issue of radical
gender theory and and child sex abuse
the texas department of health
was just asked by governor greg abbott a
simple question abbott deferring to the
agency said
is pumping little kids full of cross-sex
hormones and mutilating their bodies
because their psycho mothers think that
the little boys are little girls i think
governor abbott used more clinical
language than i did but that's obviously
the situation that we're talking about
is performing gender surgery on kids
proper medical treatment or is it child
abuse
this is a difficult question apparently
for some republicans asa hutchinson the
allegedly republican governor of of
arkansas says that it's a wonderful
medical treatment he refused to sign a
bill banning banning genital mutilation
gender surgery on little kids remember
he said no this is important medical
treatment so the texas department of
health came out and said yes it is child
abuse
genital mutilation of a child through
reassignment surgery is child abuse
subject to all rules and procedures
pertaining to child abuse such
mutilation may cause quote a genuine
threat of substantial harm from to from
physical injury to the child
good stuff
good stuff
now this raises another tricky i'm glad
we should take this win i mean we should
pursue this state by state by state to
ban the genital
gender reassignment mutilation surgery
for children obviously
but there is
an even further question here which is
if this is not medical treatment
if this really is mutilation
when you do it on children
then why are we doing it on adults
it's it's not as though reality is one
way
if you're under 18 and then reality is
completely different if you're over 18.
it's not as though a surgery is
completely different
for people who are 17 and a half
but not for 18 and a half
the
but we don't want to come to that term
in part because we so value individual
autonomy that we say well if you're a
man and you want to be a woman then you
should you should you have the right to
do that
you have you totally if you if you're a
man and you want to mutilate your body
to look more like a woman and harm
yourself in that way you totally have
the right to do that
but you don't
you don't
why do you have the right to do that
why is it
cruelty and abuse when you do it on a
child but not when you do it on an adult
because just because of the issue of
making a decision no there's more i
think there's more to
good and bad and right and wrong than
just who makes the decision making
consent is very important don't get me
wrong but i think there's more to it i
think the substance is there as well
speaking of transitions
you can't miss this today valparaiso u
university has changed its mascot from
crusaders to beacons they used to be the
crusaders now they're the beacons why
because the crusaders are very bad right
the crusaders
christian soldiers who who protected
christians in the holy land from muslim
invaders
the crusaders are bad because the
crusaders represent western civilization
and so you've got to get rid of them
they've changed it to beacon because
they say that their students should be a
beacon of hope
a beacon of hope okay
crusaders
were a beacon of hope in the late 11th
century
to the christians who were being
persecuted by muslims in the holy land
but we now take this
as just common sense we take this for
granted that anything that the west ever
did is bad
and anything that other civilizations
ever did is good
we now take it for granted that muslims
should control the holy land why
christians and jews were in the holy
land a lot longer way before the muslims
why do the muslims because the west is
bad and everyone else is good
that is the
sometimes not so tacit premise that our
education begins with and if you if you
raise generation upon generation to hate
its own civilization you're not going to
keep that civilization and you're not
going to keep those rights you're not
going to keep that way of life for very
long which we're seeing happen to us
right now
speaking of political violence
an obama appointed federal judge
has has just come out
against the biden doj specifically with
regard to the january 6th
political insurrection coup d'etat the
worst event in american history you know
that you know that thing worse than
pearl harbor worse than 1812 okay
so that this is good news right then an
obama-era judge is now coming out
against the biden doj the problem is
this judge she's coming out against the
doj because she thinks the doj is going
too light
on the on the capital rioter people
she thinks that they need harsher
punishments
already you see these guys whose worst
crime is dancing around the capitol in a
horn helmet who you know come in and
maybe they broke a window maybe not they
the one smiley guy took nancy pelosi's
lecture and you remember that not
defending it just saying
there are worse crimes in the world and
these guys are getting the books thrown
at them already
and she is saying
that they they need even harsher
punishments for terrorizing members of
congress
meanwhile as we've reported on this show
actual terrorists blm
leftist terrorists who burned down
private businesses they actually went
after civilians they killed people
they killed infinitely more people than
the capital sixth rioters did because
the capital the january 6th riders
didn't didn't kill anyone and the blm
people killed a lot of people
the the blm people who also went after
federal courthouses burned down federal
courthouses burned down police stations
they're basically getting off the hook
in manhattan and in the bronx
they're being released without any
charges in many cases and when they are
being charged they're being charged with
much less serious offenses
this
is the new normal
this is the new regime
i think a lot of conservatives believed
that if we went really really hard after
january 6th if we kind of bought into
the leftist line that january 6 was the
worst event in the history of the world
why then
maybe they'll recognize that blm was bad
too and they'll and will all get ben
will reconcile and it just didn't happen
it didn't happen
during the blm riots you had members of
elected democrats in congress
calling for more violence actually even
before that you had that sort of thing
you had the now vice president of the
united states
bailing out the rioters from jail you
had staff members for now the president
of the united states bailing the rioters
out from jail
and and they basically want the capital
conservative people to go to gitmo okay
there's and and it's not even close what
happened at the capitol on january 6th
is not even in the same
galaxy as what happened
during the blm riots city after city
after city for six to eight months it's
not even close it's nothing compared to
what blm did
and blm mostly gets off the hook
that's the real political situation
there's not going to be a negotiation
there's not going to be a come together
and you give a little and i give a
little this is a bare-knuckle political
fight over who can wield political power
more effectively
that doesn't mean that it's absent logic
and justice obviously we want to wield
political power with justice with logic
but you've got to wield
that power devin hogan chairman of the
minneapolis democratic farmer labor
party which is an affiliate of the
democratic party in minnesota
has just said quote like it or not
setting the third precinct on fire was a
genuine revolutionary moment an act of
pure righteousness to open new worlds of
understanding the people declared
themselves ungovernable and unilaterally
took their power back the largest
international human rights movement in
modern history had begun the youth of
minneapolis carried all of this the cops
started it
it doesn't get clearer than that does it
the the democrat
activist
a democrat official is a part of an
affiliate but a democrat nonetheless in
minnesota defending the burning down of
police stations and saying yeah the cops
started it i think they called that
victim blaming
that's what we're talking about and
there's something we can learn from him
when he says the people declared
themselves ungovernable and unilaterally
took their power back
the way the left did that the substance
of what they were doing was wrong it was
unjust
it was very bad
but we can do that too in a just way
we can declare ourselves ungovernable
under these unjust laws we can using
logic and persuasion and not being
terrorists like the left was but we can
assert our political right
you're seeing some people do it right
you're seeing desantis do it in florida
you're seeing some of the governors do
it
we can do that
but it does require some courage it does
that unfortunately is in short supply in
a lot of places but speaking of
terrorists
i can't leave today
before i note some actual important news
that's being swept under the rug
we just lost the war in afghanistan
we've been fighting this war in
afghanistan for 20 years now and we just
lost
we've basically officially lost the war
now the soldiers didn't lose the war
soldiers did a great job the soldiers
achieved all of their military
objectives
the political leadership did lose that
war they chose to lose that war
and they chose to lose that war
because they didn't even know what they
wanted to win
they did what was winning what is
winning the war in afghanistan
i couldn't even i couldn't even tell you
i couldn't even tell you but here's what
what i do know george w bush came out
after 9 11 and he said
those who
are harboring terrorists will be treated
as the terrorists themselves we will
make no distinction and what he was
talking about was the taliban harboring
al-qaeda terrorists and we're going to
go in and we're going to make no
distinction and you're not going to have
a moment's peace until we kill all of
you
and now the taliban is coming back
so they won and we lost
and what does jen sake the white house
press secretary have to say about this
well you know they've just got to figure
out what they want to do in the
international community
is clearly on the march your objective
is to have a negotiated political set on
what what gives you confidence the
taliban is interested in that
well the taliban has to make an
assessment one we have also said that
there's no question that the afghan
national defense security forces would
be strengthened
as would the afghan political leadership
if they were to have more success in
fighting back there's no question about
that we're not hiding from that in any
way shape or form the taliban also has
to make an assessment about what they
want their role to be in the
international community and i know that
ambassador khalilzad made comments when
he was at the political negotiations
yesterday making clear that the
international community is going to
watch closely how the taliban behaves
they have a range of tools in their
arsenal as well to take steps should
they choose well the taliban just has to
figure out what it wants its role to be
in the international community these are
the people that are governing us
that
spoiler alert the taliban doesn't want a
role in the international community okay
it took 20 years for these ruling elites
to figure that out
sometimes some some better sometimes
some worse these are the people
governing us i don't think they have any
credibility i don't think we should
follow
follow their orders follow i think we
should using every just and right and
legitimate political tool at our
disposal
fight back against them tooth and nail
before they terminate our way of life
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode vaccine passports are on
the rise the showdown between texas
republicans and democrats heats up and
the california recall election tightens
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire